the town of town mods lies at the foot
of the Matterhorn in Switzerland
the restaurants at the hotel open wolf
are among the best addresses for fine
dining in the resort one legume a
proudly boasts 15 gumi you'll points
hinesville FIBA has been the chef here
since 2002 he and his team specialize in
Hardy regional dishes black duck liver
terrine with rolled almonds he took the
shape the typical Alpine cuisine has
celebrated in zermatt has influences
from Italy in the south and from France
in the West and also from the products
we get from tirol especially in the
summer things like vegetables fruit and
berries news they threw stay pagan the
restaurant combines Mediterranean
recipes with regional products there's
roast lamb on spinach and rye bread yoki
rye bread is a mainstay of the local
cuisine
they open battle with these vices you
don't know how long rye bread has been
around probably thousands of years and
the history of rye bread takes us to
Finland that's a small village near at
ser mas boy game Rai has always been
farmed there it's the only green little
grow at this altitude to get the guy did
a selfie sick who in your face who FIBA
gets his rye bread from nabina bakery
which can look back at three generations
in business rye bread comes with the
seal of quality here that confirms that
the rye was locally grown and the bread
made by qualified bakers vinas rye bread
is baked according to a family recipe
this is a nun and broadened long advance
it's a bread with a long tradition it
stays fresh for a long time my
grandparents used to bake it in the
autumn and then they stored it all
winter sponsored mental invasion uber
gay logins done hot money we got it out
broke off a piece and danced it in warm
milk it was really good to eat jeevana
me cats kittens pokemon as matrix a good
SE co FIBA is making a dessert out of
rye bread it's a mousse with saffron
pears first he warms up the milk with a
vanilla pod then he pours it over the
cubes of rye bread and leaves it to
stand for about 20 minutes ah so hdd's
it's important that the milk is totally
absorbed and there aren't any more lumps
the Moose has to be really smooth
to make the Moose he gently whisks egg
yolks and sugar for about five minutes
until they become fluffy in the meantime
he dissolves gelatin in warm white wine
then the liquid is stirred into the egg
mixture and then the bread and finally
he mixes in some cream and leaves the
mousse to chill
he peels the pears and uses a melon
scoop to cut out small balls which he
vents simmers in white wine with saffron
the cds dvds are williams pair and
they've taken on a beautiful saffron
color they were cooked for between 10
and 20 minutes it's best to use a
dessert spoon to arrange the dish add a
spoon of stewed elderberries then finish
off the mousse with warm balls of
saffron pair
guests will find out that bread can be
much more than just a side order to a
main dish at the hotel ivanhoe in samut